what is the p-value and how is it
interpreted that's what we will discuss
in this video let's start with an
example we would like to investigate
whether there is a difference in height
between the average American man and the
average American basketball player
the average American man is
1.77 meters tall
so we want to know if the average
American basketball player is also
1.77 meters tall thus we State the null
hypothesis the average height of an
American basketball player is 1.77
meters
so we assume that in the population of
American basketball players the average
height is
1.77 meters
however since we cannot serve the entire
population we draw a sample of course
this sample will not yield an exact mean
of 1.77 that would be very unlikely
it may be that the sample drawn purely
by chance deviates by three centimeters
deviates by 8 centimeters deviates by 15
centimeters purely by chance differs by
any other value
since we are testing an undirected
hypothesis that is we only want to know
if there is a difference
we do not care in which direction the
difference goes
so now we come to the p-value
as said we assume that in the population
there is a mean value of 1.77 if we draw
a sample it will differ from the
population by a certain value the
p-value now tells us How likely it is to
draw a sample
that deviates from the population
by an equal or greater amount than the
observed value let's take a closer look
again
so we have a sample that is different
from the population we are now
interested in How likely it is to draw a
sample that deviates as much as our
sample or more from the population
thus the p-value indicates How likely it
is to draw a sample whose mean is in
this range
if by chance our sample deviates by
three centimeters from 1.77 the p-value
tells us How likely it is to draw a
sample that deviates three centimeters
or more from the population
if by chance our sample deviates by 9
centimeters from 1.77 the p-value tells
us How likely it is to draw a sample
that deviates nine centimeters or more
from the population an example we get a
difference of 9 centimeters and our
favorite statistics software EG data tab
calculates a p-value of
0.03 IE three percent this now tells us
that it is only three percent likely to
draw a sample that is equal to or more
than nine centimeters different from the
population
for normally distributed data this means
the probability that the mean lies in
this range is 1.5 percent that the mean
lies in this range is also 1.5 percent
likely and together three percent
if this probability is very low one can
of course ask whether the sample comes
from a population with a mean of
1.77 meters at all it is just a
hypothesis that the mean value of
basketball players is
1.77 meters and it is precisely this
hypothesis that we want to test
therefore if we calculated a very small
p-value this gave us an evidence that
the mean of the population is not 1.77
meters at all thus we would reject the
null hypothesis which assumes that the
mean is 1.77 meters but at what point is
the p-value small enough to reject the
null hypothesis this is determined with
the so-called significance level also
called Alpha level there are two things
to notice here one very important the
significance level is always determined
prior to the study and cannot be changed
afterwards in order to finally obtain
the desired results two to ensure a
certain degree of comparability the
significance level is usually set at
five percent or one percent a p-value of
less than one percent is considered
highly significant less than five
percent is called significant and
greater than five percent is called not
significant summary the p-value gives us
an indication of whether or not we
reject the null hypothesis as a reminder
the null hypothesis assumes that there
is no difference in contrast the
alternative hypothesis assumes that
there is a difference in general the
null hypothesis is rejected if the
p-value is smaller than 0.05 however as
we know it is always only a probability
and we can be wrong without a statement
if the null hypothesis is true in the
population IE the mean is 1.77 meters
but we draw a sample that happens to be
quite far away it might be that the
p-value is smaller than 0.05 so that we
wrongly reject the null hypothesis this
is called type 1 error if in the
population the null hypothesis is false
I.E the mean is not 1.77 meters but we
draw a sample that happened to be very
close to 1.77 meters the p-value may be
larger than 0.05 and we may not reject
the null hypothesis this is called type
2 error and now I will show you how you
can easily calculate the p-value for a
variety of hypothesis tests online with
data tab to do this simply visit data
dot net copy your own data into this
table
and click on hypothesis test depending
on which variables you click on data tab
will suggest a hypothesis test for
example a t-test chi-square test Anova
wilcoxon test and many more for example
if you click on salary and gender a
t-test for independent samples is
automatically calculated
if you click on salary and Company for
example an analysis of variance is
automatically calculated
if your data is not normally distributed
you can also calculate the
non-parametric counterpart
if you now scroll down you will find the
p-value
if you are not sure about the
interpretation you can click on
interpretation in words a one-factor
analysis of variance has shown that
there is no difference between the
categorical variable company and the
variable salary thus with the available
data the null hypothesis is not rejected
thanks for watching I hope to see you
soon